be fairly safe oh he's berserked  i'm here to take your time enjoy  enjoy the game there's only three  minutes left  this is wow probably  [Music]  great compensation  lulu berserking yeah who wouldn't  actually he's sort of playing me but  it's fine  yeah i'm gonna see berserk  now he's thinking and he can't afford to  do that  and he's the fastest groundmaster in the  world online probably so  probably in ultra bullet he's probably  the fastest  at least yeah but in hype i think it's  close  yeah but anyways he's  damn fast damn the cat i'm the cat  i'm not even paying attention to  position because that's why when i was  i think i could have buy a new computer  mask i was just  figuring out which mouse he had because  i thought i'd like  there we go oh this is that's beautiful